as soon as I said like I found out about
you guys like a couple months ago okay
and I was in New York and I just was
binge watching your [ __ ] thanks to Silas
myotis who I just signed oh hey what's
up man and I just couldn't get over it
sugar yeah oh yeah thank you it was
incredible and what was even its more
insane is how just upset he was about
being called sugar gay and then goes on
to say like the most gayest stuff not
that there's anything wrong does
anything wrong with that but I just
thought it was great and how you guys
handled it is good thank you man
weird we were talking about this a
little bit yesterday cuz like he he now
knows about the video really yeah
bro but he doesn't get it was like a bit
that it's a joke yeah it takes it really
really seriously and he like our
sometimes our fans will go up to him and
say it and he'll get really mad and
he'll be like that's homophobic but how
are you calling somebody homophobic when
you were like saying all this like
homophobic [ __ ] in the video because I
think he's like taking a hard 180 yeah
like this is only wedding it's actually
for two years of my life everywhere I
went it was biracial jokes like yeah
it's okay you go with it like it doesn't
matter like it's a [ __ ] jokes yes I
get it I don't know I think it's funny
though I think you guys are pretty
hilarious especially now because I mean
I definitely think that everything you
you guys have taste and you know what
you say and I think with any great
writer or comedian you don't you you
don't create jokes and and and kind of
do them at the expense of someone right
really like they're there like to hurt
someone right and I love it cuz I think
you guys are hilarious like you gotta
have tough skin
yeah it's have tough skin it's like
you're gay you know yeah you guys in no
way are going in on non-community of
people not know exactly Thank You Man we
appreciate that yeah that's what we try
to do and you try to make it so
everybody can have fun even if it's like
at your expense is still it's not like
designed to make you feel like you're a
bad person or like you go home feeling
like [ __ ] like I said I feel about
Chappelle
yeah like Chappelle makes fun of
everybody including their own people
black people yeah it's like if you can
if you can make fun of everybody and
essentially allow all of us to laugh at
each other it kind of takes the power
away of all the negative [ __ ] that's
going on
personally that's how I feel but it's
just at the same time as like it's not
that deep everybody wants to be pissed
off you know sometimes it feels that way
man it feels like you know everybody's
trying to spark Flint and just do a
little something that's like read real
deep in the [ __ ] did you say spark
Flint's yeah I don't know what does that
mean like what like I know but like what
is that a phrase no it's not it just I
just feel like everyone tries to take
something small and like make it big
really like I'm gonna put that on
merchandise yeah start Flint yeah baby
yeah that's gangsta steal it I like that
sighs no that's fine sugar yeah yeah oh
man nice eyes dude I got the I got the
thug compliment right there I used to
get that in high school all the time
what I'm like the Mexicans and stuff
they'd be like a fool you got nice eyes
they talk about jumpin me in to make up
for it I'm like this fine you can true I
could take a commie great so how's it
going is it okay that I'm eating oatmeal
right now dude yes much worse yes we
only eat much worse on the podcast you
don't even want to know what we've eaten
I mean we've done a Taco Bell [ __ ] mid
podcast I know it's all how do you guys
edit your videos cuz I think they're
done so great oh thank you I mean
usually the best kind stuff he he cuts
them yeah just uh you know standard
editing [ __ ] just like takes forever but
don't be don't be certain like little
just like the most my new amount of pull
in freeze frame for a second but it's
like the it's the comedic timing is
really great yeah well yeah we're not
funny so I have to make us funny editing
yeah and just said you know the punches
on the face that's an easy that's an
easy formula and I think it's great I
loved the one about the I still got to
dive into all of them because I've
frickin binge
like aged three like Ethan and Neela no
Ange that and I just became such huge
fans of theirs and and you run their
podcast too right
I was yeah that was amazing they're
really both really sweet and haven't
talked to him in a watcher probably text
them I know they had their little teddy
yeah yeah dog their little baby
whatever that is but yes there was a
void
I was I was devoid of great what is it
forward-thinking comedic power thanks
dude
and then I got this yeah I got this I
saw this video and no yeah now we're
here but yo how about those like
Christian chicks yeah dude not that I'm
going at Christianity religion by the
way now man we were talking about this
the other day they have they had a beef
yeah recently with two other Christian
girls
oh [ __ ] Christian beef yeah yeah they
basically and I know you thought your
Abba Blee thinking like what does that
entail
right we were wondering the same thing
and it's it's because did - girl - fine
girl's question the other ones faith
yeah
and so they got really mad which is
probably probably we didn't probably bro
like older season it's where it's where
Cartman like tries to go platinum and he
finds out that it's like so hard to go
platinum so he starts oh right yeah he
starts a Christian band yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Jesus beef no right it's actually pretty
it's pretty gangster because they they
sat down on their beautiful white snow
background and they basically looked a
camera and it was like you're not about
it you're not about God and then old
Christian mother clap back she said of
her camera to her beautiful ass [ __ ] and
she was like yes I am and they've just
been kind of dishing it out have you
guys done a video on this yet no we
haven't
it's what we want to leave them alone a
little bit yeah yeah yeah is it ever
hard like where people don't realize
it's just a joke no I mean they they
hate like they definitely hate the
videos like you know people are usually
cool about it right like the the one we
did on the kombucha guy like he invited
us over afterwards and like and people
are usually like cool with us after we
do a video on them we'll talk about it
and we can meet up with them and
whatever but they the two girls like
they they hate us yeah
but you are a sinning pieces of [ __ ] we
are yeah hundred percent we deserve it
yeah that's true dude they wrote a they
wrote a big ass they wrote 300 bars
about us - really yeah they were going
in it's a little different though cuz it
is like you are touching on their faith
a little bit so it's like of course
they're gonna feel some type of way and
look at you to the devil but it's you're
like you're going to hell we're going to
hell you know I mean that we're not I
could be the nicest you could be the
sweetest person in the world but like oh
thank you man I don't know I'm open yeah
I'm open to hell what would they say
they were like I say wrote like a like a
like a five-paragraph Instagram post it
was crazy it was like we got 6 million
views on YouTube
it's our most popular video the only
problem is we didn't make it and then
there was just like these man and now
we've done two videos on them I feel
like yeah that's like very adult of you
because you realizing like oh we could
still do this it would still be funny
but we don't want it to become like yeah
whole thing yeah it's a big deal 2019
yeah yeah plus they already got their
own now they have their own beefs to
worry about yeah it's kind of funny that
it's like a legit beef like wine is the
religion like there it's just like any
other beef is it you're not really about
which life yeah is it kosher B I mean by
the Judaism yeah yeah it ain't kosher
that's for sure
no they're doing all the same stuff
they're making music videos about each
other down pandit now I'm jaded every
bad funny though you know the Christian
diss track would that be like pray
asking me fo yeah see you he's actually
a really nice guy no I'm sorry
yeah yeah lecrae you like that okay
I just keep Mary it's fine EKKO looks
really isn't NF
isn't he like a Christian rapper too did
he start as a Christian rap I don't know
yeah technically
yeah I think so we've kind of had that
conversation sorry I my step no no no
I'm turning so we've we've had that
conversation but yeah he's definitely a
man of faith but he also just loves rap
there's no reason you can't like both
yeah unless you do it like I do yeah
but uh but um do you know him I know
this dry humor is knowing me yeah we
went on tour once oh really yeah last
year right it was him and SuperDuper
Kyle Oh though how's Kyle he seems like
a really nice guy that dude is a piece
of [ __ ] oh god no I can't [ __ ] with him
I'm serious there's like I don't talk
[ __ ] about a lot of people that's one
guy I don't [ __ ] with you're kidding
right no man he said some [ __ ]
you should've owned the store really
yeah but we'll talk about it oh well no
I'm just kidding you played that really
well man just holy [ __ ] yeah
moving on datacom exclusive for me
[Music]